crenn bonjour bonjour alors on est très
content de parler avez-vous l'arabie
saoudite qui est un pays qui vous
passionne depuis longtemps et j'aimerais
qu'on commence par la sphère khashoggi
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
découvert le prince ben salman pendant
qu'on apprenait un peu ce qui s'était
passé le meurtre terrible de ce
journaliste saoudien en turquie on
aurait pu penser que le prince ben
salman aurait été déstabilisé un peu
fragilisé par par cette affaire or il
semble bien en poste qu'est ce que vous
en comprenait il est certain que le
l'assassinât de cet éditorialiste qui
appartenait à une grande famille
saoudienne et et qui lui même avait fait
son parcours à l'intérieur du système
ce qui explique la dangerosité telle
qu'elle était perçue évidemment par le
prince héritier et par ryad
ça n'excuse en rien cet assassinat
atroce mais il est certain que cet
épisode a tout à coup projeter sur ce
jeune prince héritier qui avait été
accueilli en occident comme un
modernisateur il avait d'ailleurs vendu
avec un grand talent de séduction et
beaucoup d'habileté ce visage n'est tout
à coup et projeté sur lui
cette lumière sombre et atroce et
sanglante
pourquoi est ce qu'il n'a pas été
destitué parce que les critères qui sont
les nôtres sont et on peut on doit le
regretter évidemment pas ceux qui sont à
l'oeuvre dans cette partie du monde
s'est il est évident que le vieux roi
n'allez pas dire excusez moi je me suis
trompé de fils je vais en prendre un
autre
parce que c'est lui qui l'a choisie
comme prince hériter il choisit ce fils
là qui n'est pas non plus son fils aîné
mais qui est l'aîné de son épouse
favorite et il le choisit parce que ce
mot ahmed surnommé la can de son père
depuis l'adolescence à l'accompagner
partout dans toutes les cérémonies
tribale dont les cérémonies religieuses
il est il est totalement pénétré de la
culture saoudienne à la différence de
ses frères aînés
il n'a pas fait d'études en occident du
tout il a fait des
études de droit à l'université de ryad
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'étudier le
droit le droit dans ces pays c'était
utile quand elle apprendre par coeur
une formation intellectuelle quand même
très très limité il a la réputation ce
jeune prince d'être très dynamique très
est tout à fait intelligent très à
l'affût
passionné par la technologie passionné
par la finance et se mohamed qui a
maintenant 33 ans est extrêmement
populaire dans un pays où 70% de la
population a moins de 30 ans et tout à
coup dans une société totalement
corsetée asphyxier les jeunes en
particulier avec la ségrégation entre
les garçons et les filles jusqu'à ce
jeune prince héritier interdiction
absolue de la musique du cinéma des feux
d'artifice du sport et c'est tout à coup
se mohamed pour cette jeunesse en tout
cas et ça le roi le comprend très bien
ce mohamed est un héros et la place et
le rôle et la légitimité du prince
héritier dans l'ordre dynastique
cautionner comme toujours en arabie
soudite il faut jamais l'oublier par le
pouvoir religieux
cette légitimité n'est pas remise en
cause
il permet quand même et on en a beaucoup
parlé dans les pays occidentaux aux
femmes de conduire c'est une grande
avancée quand même oui cap qui peut
apparaître comme dérisoire pour nous
mais qui par rapport encore une fois à
un système social et religieux
totalement oppressant et d'abord pour
les femmes évidemment traiter comme des
créatures de second ordre et avec un
système social qui leur empêche tout
espace de liberté we7 tellement
révolutionnaire qui lie à une bonne
partie de prédicateur religieux qui ont
de aussi découvert les réseaux sociaux
et qui se répandent en consterné en
ville ni en disant mais quelle horreur
elles n'ont pas de cerveau donc qu'elles
savent pas quand il faudra tourner à
gauche ou à droite ou alors c'est très
mauvais pour le revers de conduire elle
pourrait ne plus jamais avoir d'enfant
enfin des trucs mais inimaginable
néanmoins c'est une réforme qui
évidemment fait ses grands pieds
spectaculaire qui fait qui fait grand
bruit mais qui accompagne d'autres
efforts pour desserrer encore une fois
ce ce corset social le prince mohammed
bin salman vous désirez quoi un
réformateur ou un leader autoritaire
finalement un dictateur il incarne un
pouvoir absolu dont les critères échappe
totalement au à notre propre manière de
concevoir le pouvoir politique et les
réformes ont été accompagnées d'une
répression de plus en plus dur c'est à
dire qu'il a mis en prison
systématiquement d'un côté ce qu'on
appellerait nous des progressistes et
notamment des films des militantes
féministes dont on dit qu'elles ont été
torturés en plus
et d'un autre côté les
ultra-conservateurs c'est à dire les
religieux critiquant ses réformes et
accusant en fait ce jeune prince
contrevenir aux règles de l'islam
wahhabite
on a vu ce qu'il a fait au canada quand
la ministre des affaires étrangères
kutcher ellen a réclamé la libération
immédiate de la soeur de rise badaoui
donc qui est un blogueur qui est
emprisonné l'arabie saoudite aurait été
emprisonné par l'europe précédent oui et
qui toujours là qu'il ya eu une reçu des
coups de fouet et c'est mai et dont la
famille est maintenant canadienne donc
on l'a vu à quel point sa réaction a été
très forte à l'égard du canada quoi la
colère les réactions démesurées
spectaculaire aucune solidarité hélas
vis-à-vis d'ottawa ni de la part de
washington en face on pouvait s'y
attendre ni d'aucune autre donc une
capitale européenne d'ailleurs temps
l'arabie saoudite est importante à la
fois sur l'échiquier régional face à
l'iran et bien évidemment sur le plan
économique cause du pétrole des contrats
d'armement où lé contrat d'armement tous
les pays sont un peu tributaire de les
pays occidentaux sont un peu tributaire
de ça mais ça nous en dit beaucoup sur
les méthodes non de ce prince en tout
cas ça éclaire un tempérament volcanique
et il est évident que cet épisode a été
d'une certaine manière prémonitoire de
de cet assassinat épouvantable de cash
audi et qui est d'autant plus comment
dire absurde qu'on voit bien hélas dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui toutes sortes de
régimes autoritaires qui ont des
manières beaucoup plus maligne de se
débarrasser de leurs opposants il faut
oui bon c'était quand même chose mais
dans un consulat
non mais ça a été aussi exploiter
politiquement de façon il faut dire
extrêmement habile par le président turc
erdogan qui a vu l'occasion du millier
ce jeune prince saoudien à qui il
dispute la domination du monde sunnite
est aussi d'embarrasser l'administration
trump et on voit d'ailleurs que donald
trump ne cesse depuis de dire à quel
point
erdogan est un grand homme et la turquie
un allié essentiel du nid on l'a dit
assez pressé ce princesse que d'après
vous il va pouvoir mener à bien ses
réformes
et est-ce qu'il va rester est ce qu'il
va pouvoir durer parce que c'est la
question au fond pas la boule de cristal
mais on voit bien que c'est tout
derniers jours
encore une fois le vieux roi a installé
autour du prince héritier dont la
légitimité encore une fois n'a jamais
été remise en cause
il a installé le virois un espèce de
cordon de sage ou en tout cas de gens
plus âgés
il a remanié ce qui a eu enfin le
gouvernement il a changé quelques
ministres clés notamment demi les
affaires étrangères une manière de
donner des gages à ceux à washington en
particulier au sein du parti républicain
qui ont beaucoup critiqué ryad depuis
l'assassinât de cachot guy blouet le
congrès le tient responsable d'ailleurs
de cet assassinat
oui mais
imagine pas que washington met une croix
sur les 110 milliards de dollars de
contrats d'armements qui n'ont toujours
pas été signé par l'arabie saudite même
si vous avez raison l'accord du congrès
nécessaire mais donald trump et son
gendre sont extrêmement proches de mbs
et il est évident que cette proximité ne
va pas être remise en cause de sitôt
donc une grosse secousse
après l' affaire qui a choqué certes
mais à moyen terme en tout cas pas de
remise en cause fondamentale me
semble-t-il du pouvoir à ryad
le paradoxe c'est que le prince héritier
qui à 33 ans intérêt à ce que son vieux
père de 82 ans vivent le plus longtemps
possible de façon à être abrité en
quelque sorte par la légitimité du vieux
roi le plus longtemps possible et de
façon à ce que les réformes qui dont
bénéficie avec sans aucune liberté mais
dont bénéficie malgré tout la jeunesse
continuent de porter leurs fruits dans
une conjoncture économique qui reste lié
aux prix du pétrole
et là évidemment cette conjoncture est
devenue moins favorable avec un prix du
pétrole qui avaient semé n'aurait pu
continuer à en parler longtemps de ce
pays qui est quand même assez fascinant
et on connaît très peu
merci beaucoup madame aux craintes merci
à vous